[Musique]
au salon de l'agriculture se tiendra du
samedi 24 février au dimanche 4 mars
2018 porte de versailles à paris une
conférence de presse s'est tenue ce
vendredi 16 février en présence des
principaux partenaires la chambre
d'agriculture le département d île de la
réunion tourisme et la région suite à un
appel à candidatures vingt exposants
réunionnais participeront à cet
événement oui c'est une bonne chose que
si on n'a pas cette organisation là on
n'aurait pas pu participer à cet
événement là c'est la première fois
qu'on participe en tant qu'exposant ça
le seul salon bah quoi nous le but c'est
de faire connaître belle ne trouve ne
produira le thé de la réunion à
l'extérieur aussi
et ces mecs n'avaient pas ce coup de
pouce au niveau des stands vous n'aurez
pas personnellement tu participes j'ai
découvert qu'avec le va quoi on pouvait
faire de multitudes de choses
donc j'aimerais promouvoir ce produit de
la réunion est vraiment l'emmener au
delà de la réunion ex province est
l'occasion dans ce set foire agricole de
paris de faire promouvoir notre va quoi
réunionnais un village spécial réunion
est de 600 mètres carrés s'installera
dans le salon le budget total s'élève à
650 2000 euros le département finance
550000 euros
la collectivité souhaite créer de
nouveaux réseaux et offrir des débouchés
aux exposants la grande nouveauté que
nous aurons sur sa ce salon
international de l'agriculture
c'est tout simplement qu'avec que le
partenariat engagé avec la région
liberté syndicat du sucre
nous aurons enfin un village de la
réunion avec une unicité dans la
représentation et uniformité dans un les
stands lâche andré futur a travaillé
pour véritablement installé ses 24
exposants au lieu de neuf c'est aussi
une très grande nouveauté 24 exposants
c'est la première fois que nous serons
aussi un nombreux pour représenter les
valeurs de la réunion la réunion notre
identité nos cultures nos savoir-faire
les produits péi qui seront donc sur les
différents stands que nous proposons à
l'ensemble des visiteurs
le but étant de leur
faciliter des contacts avec des
entreprises nationales et
internationales
c'est pour ça que nous avons travaillé
énormément pour pouvoir permettre qu'il
y ait des rendez vous lors de ce salon
pour qu'il y ait des échanges pour que
cela se concrétise bien entendu par des
actions commerciales au bénéfice bien
sûr de nos entreprises et faire
reconnaître les qualités de nos produits
réunionnais nous profitons de la culture
pour faire la promotion de la
destination la promotion de nos artisans
la promotion de nos produits péi de nos
produits réunionnais pour pouvoir aussi
ensuite après les ventes mais aussi
vendre aussi de notre destination pour
que les visiteurs de ce salon viennent
chez nous c'est un c'est une première
nous allons tous unis à ce salon de
l'agriculture
et nous aurons ainsi une vitrine de la
réunion sans précédent nous n'avons
jamais connu jusqu'à présent
une belle occasion d'exporter le
savoir-faire réunionnais dans cet
événement fréquenté par plus de six cent
mille visiteurs
[Musique]